[Laughter]
[Music]
how you guys doing i wanted to share
something just amazing with you did you
read about this we posted on our
facebook page we shared it on social
media too so make sure subscribe here
right now hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on
posts like this now before i get into
this bbc news report that's actually
talking about the sunnah of the last and
final message sent to mankind prophet
muhammed peace and blessings be upon him
this is amazing subscribe right now so
you don't miss
our shows that come out videos like this
hit that notification bell i want to
share a true story with you a good
friend of mine
shared the story with me it's a true
story dr ahmet sabil when he had his
baby he said that
the doctors came in they did these tests
and the baby's blood sugar was really
low so they were getting ready to put
all these injections in the baby and
what he did was you know we have this
what we do when the baby's born you
recite the then
the baby's ear god is the greatest god
is the greatest
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator the heavens and earth allah
a testifying muhammad is his messenger
and come to prayer come to prayer come
to success come to success that's the
adhan and then you also have some other
practices but one of them here is the
taking of the date look the date and the
natural sugars in a date and rubbing it
inside of the baby's mouth so dr sabil
ahmed he did this
he did it while everyone stepped out of
the hospital room so what happens next
they run back they do all the tests and
then they come back check the tests as
they're about to go ahead and intervene
because the baby sugar's
blood sugar is very low low and behold
after
dr sabil ahmed after he did this
sunnah
a place in the date inside with the
natural sugars in the baby's mouth
the blood sugar level went back to where
it's supposed to be it got regulated
properly alhamdulillah now take it to
what i wanted to share with you that we
know over 1400 years ago when a babe was
born the prophet muhammad peace and
blessed be upon it made it his sunnah
his way to do this practice that we're
doing today look at that and we know in
the sunnahs there's barakah there's
wisdom so now we have this bbc news
report coming out saying that a dose of
sugar given in a gel rubbed into the
cheek of the baby is a cheap and
effective way to protect premature
babies against brain damage say experts
dangerously low blood sugar affects
about 1 in 10 babies born too early
untreated it can cause permanent harm
researchers from new zealand testified
that gel therapy and 242 babies under
their care and based on the results say
it should now be the first line of
treatment their work is published in the
land sid so alhamdulillah isn't this
amazing so when you look back and you
see the quran verbatim word of god
almighty has signs in there that it is
indeed from the creators of heavens and
earth and i'll give you the good news so
stay to the end i got some good news i
got a gift for you if you're not yet
muslim if you're looking into islam
you're looking for the purpose of life
why are you being created while you're
here i gotta have a gift for you so stay
soon stay tuned so now we have so many
evidences that islam because it's not
blind faith you have the quran the meat
and potatoes of it like the main
evidence the prophecies in the quran the
miracles are splitting of the moon the
development of the human being the list
goes on
so imagine prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him if you put a
green for check
right
and a red for wrong some things that he
got right some things that got wrong
he's not getting anything wrong if you
go to the experts in these areas of
embryology of zoology a biology whatever
science and you go to not some guy on
youtube you know who's
you know using his expertise on making
uh videos against islam to go ahead and
give his bias interpretation no you go
to the experts and now the experts are
in line
and they're like okay this actually like
the
the barrier that's between that the
quran talks about between the two waters
right it's there in the quran so now you
have the preservation of the quran it's
there the message the message of just
worshiping one and only one god and
being morally upright the list goes on
and then when you study the life of
prophet muhammad the prophecies that he
talked about the events to come that had
passed that he talked about things that
are just unimaginable that this man
living in the desert 1400 years ago
would know so now you have green red
green is for a check off how many things
are right and then red how many things
are wrong i give the example of
nostradamus just one simple example
people get caught up with you know many
of the things that nostradamus had
supposedly predicted
and now these vague it's very just like
heart is very esoteric and
it's hard to you know kind of pinpoint
but he might have one thing possibly
that is something that might have came
true maybe one very vague but they
forget about all of the check boxes in
the red that were totally false if you
don't have that with prophet muhammad
peace and muslim you don't have that so
that's not fallib how is that
imaginable fallible how can that
possibly be now we talk about we have
the major evidences that if anyone's
sincere
open-minded they take a scientific
analytical approach and they look at the
quran and they're fascinated right off
the get-go of the message
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one who created you created me the
one who jesus prayed to moses abraham
last and final message of prophet
muhammad peace and blessed be upon him
simple message to be morally upright and
the foundation is the tohi the pure
monotheism and now it's based on
evidence upon evidence because the crown
is a living miracle now we come to the
sunnah now we come to these examples
it's amazing this is just one of them
just one of them that now i gave you the
true example this is anecdotal you know
but then you have the researchers from
the bbc news report published in the
lancet
it is amazing look at that so those
people who are upon the sunnah there's
barakah in it don't ever go away from it
and we're
taking this chance to revive this sunnah
to revive the sunnah and the prophet saw
said the one who revised my sunnah will
have the reward of those who do it so
inshallah we got a chance to revive this
sunnah to increase some people's iman
because when they look at the details
and then also the meat and potatoes the
vegetables and all these things together
there's no way that this man could be
speaking from himself
no he's speaking from divine revelation
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him and it's not blind faith would
you just jumping into this blindly
you're using the faculties that god
almighty the creator allah has given you
and you look at the ample amount of
evidence that is there that the quran is
indeed from the creator god almighty
that prophet muhammad is indeed the last
and final messenger sent to mankind and
then you look at his sunnah for those
people who are practicing it look at the
blessings of this just this sunnah so
try your best not to neglect
the sunnahs that are there there's great
wisdom behind them because it is indeed
from the creator of the heavens and
earth who's inspiring prophet muhammad
and i told you i promised you a gift
that's right for those people who are
liking what we have to say they want to
learn more
they're sick of hearing all this
false
propaganda that's out there against
islam
they know when they watch our shows that
many of these things we debunk they see
that hold on i don't like being lied to
i really want to get to know islam for
myself
go ahead and visit us at thedeenshow.com
and get now you can get your on us
free copy of the quran that's right go
to thedeenshow.com and now it's a gift
from me to you go ahead and get your
free copy of the quran and after you
read it i want to hear back from you
many have accepted islam submission to
the creator not the creation go ahead
and send us a message let us know your
experience and maybe you need some
assistance too go ahead you have some
questions email us so for those who have
read the quran accepted it we want to
hear your stories those people are
thinking about it just have a few
questions
go ahead those want to take shahada go
ahead contact us
and hopefully you benefit from this news
report
from the bbc
talking about this sunnah of prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
thank you very much go ahead and
subscribe if you have in the beginning
right now support our work you know my
team tells me you've got to go ahead and
tell the people to like
uh you got to tell them to if it was me
i just leave you alone on this but you
got to remind them to hit the
notification bell you got a reminder do
the like that's all part of helping the
videos grow so we can get to more people
more people can benefit from this
inshallah and support us on our patreon
page we'll see you next time inshaallah
god willing until then peace be with you
assalamu alaikum